this car is 1 meter 74 wide and 4 meters
42 long and belongs to the compact class
the best sellers in the segment come
from the big players afford focus toyota
corolla and volkswagen golf but this
compact car is made by the automotive
division of japan's fuji heavy
industries in other words it's the new
Subaru Impreza the income and the
compact class is as competitive as it
gets as our car reviewer Android one new
trend we're seeing in the segment is
manufacturers seeking to combine more
engine versions and vehicles with wheel
drive and hip hop in oil and here client
Subaru and says anything you can do we
can pursue now the car maker does have a
long tradition in all-wheel drive and
the Impreza represents a nice price
rival to the Gulf and is only available
with or wheel drive we tried out the
top-of-the-line edition of the employer
with xenon lights rear view camera and
adaptive cruise control the two-liter
boxer engine generates 110 kilowatts of
power all in all it will cost you twenty
five thousand three hundred and fifty
euros in Germany
that's me on some tests fancy one
Android really appreciates is how the
test car pulls away so swiftly so if
you're out and about on city streets
with this 2 liter engine dimp razor you
needn't worry about slowing other road
users down but Subaru wouldn't be the
world's biggest producer of all-wheel
drive passenger cars if it didn't have
some very special setup Subaru calls its
symmetrical all-wheel drive whereas most
car makers in the compact segment have
systems that only engage the rear wheels
when the front wheels slip the
impressive boasts permanent 5050 will
drive the bios version in addition to
all wheel drive explains Android Subaru
is also a fan of boxer engines which
then lower the car center of gravity the
elementary physics will tell you that
this in turn impress handling if the
weight will hire up there'd be a bigger
tendency to roll when driving around
bends what sources done in an event
Megan rising about egged so the
appraisers handling benefits big time
here there's no oversteer and no
understeer will target your curve steer
into it and just drive monsey take over
it's bright lint fetish unless he signs
or to optimize
in purely visual terms the interior
seems on the Spartan side but our test
car did have a leather steering wheel
and a multifunctional display above the
infotainment system a rear axle used to
power the car often means less cargo
space but with the rear bench up the
Impreza is certainly a match for the
class leader the gulf as all as for the
rest of the interior at first andrew
found the seats a little too soft and
the steering wheel is on the skinny side
he likes a bit more to hold on tape on
can see a fellatio this since umaga
regard as a global definition Havana
missing Mohammed reallove 11 as missing
graphic avira
while other manufacturers reserved
all-wheel drive for higher price
segments you can get it here for as
little as 18 thousand six hundred euros
the Subaru Impreza is a car for drivers
with their very own style or for people
who don't live in the city
line facet overall and Roy says the
Impreza is an ideal option if you live
up in the hills with frequent snow and
other challenging road conditions with
its all-wheel expertise this is
something of an insider tip especially
with regard to the price tag for editing
by Dean place